show the report has just been published
I mean the key point that Richard short
was emphasizing there is that this was a
potential breach rather than an actual
breach
but nonetheless Ian it was a breach of
the code Adam happenedstall making it
clear that uh that Richard Sharp should
have mentioned that uh conflict of
interest he should have mentioned it in
his report and towards the bottom uh
Miss happenstyle writes Mr Sharp should
have made the disclosure set out in this
key findings section ultimately the BBC
chairman has jumped before I think
pressure built which would have led to
him ultimately being pushed there were
two ways out of this one he could have
resigned the procedure for removing a
BBC chair involved the Secretary of
State for culture Consulting with the
BBC board ultimate I suppose Richard
sunac might have been the the decision
maker uh telling his his uh Secretary of
State what to do that would have been
ugly you know we're likely to get a
reaction in the in the coming minutes to
that report from the labor party from
opposition parties and from uh MPS on
the culture select committee remember
that selectment has already been
incredibly critical of Mr Sharp saying
that he breached the stand as expected
that this was a significant error of
judgment therefore I think it's was the
recognition of Mr Sharp that it would
have been too difficult to stay on and
as he said in that statement it would
have really damaged the BBC's reputation
which already has been battered by a
number of uh rails including the Gary
linear Corral but this has been uh
swirling around for a number of months
and clearly it's not good for the
corporation ultimately the fact that
Richard Sharp didn't tell either the
culture committee when he gave evidence
or the appointment panel when applying
for the job about his role in
facilitating that this loan did for him
now he he argues as as he explained in
that statement that Mr happenstall
agrees he didn't play a key role in any
role in facilitating arranging or
financing the loan to Boris Johnson and
allies of Mr Sharp I've spoken to have
said that
um it is it is agreed that he he did not
know until it appeared later in the in
the media and he was he was asked about
this by journalists that there would be
a loan or loan guarantee but of course
he did have contact with Sam Blythe then
went to the cabinet secretary at Simon
case that was Mr abenstar argues a
conflict of interest he should have
mentioned when applying for this very
senior a high paid job on a pretty high
salary 160 a thousand pounds a year and
therefore he has decided to go now Ian
what happens next well he's gonna uh
stand uh reign in position until
a replacement is found so he's going to
be in position for a few more months but
clearly a very embarrassing episode for
uh Mr Sharp also I think perhaps his
decision today saves Rishi sunak from
having to make a difficult decision we
know the prime minister is appearing
later today in Scotland and Wales at
party conferences the Scottish concern
to Party Conference in the Welsh
conservatives a Party Conference likely
I'm sure to be asked about this but the
fact that Mr Sharp has acted and acted
fast at doing that statement recording
that statement with the BBC even before
the report was released to all of us I
think was has saved Rishi sunak uh some
difficult uh difficult questions and he
argued Mr Sharp argues it saves also the
BBC for a more difficult uh painful
headlines he said that what he did was
with the best of intentions he claims
there's no evidence he played any part
in the facilitation Arrangement or
financing of that loan to Boris Johnson
but also there was regret there he
regretted as he said that he hadn't
mentioned this to the two to the panel
and to the culture select committee he
apologized to BBC staff for the
distraction he has been in recent weeks
and now his time as BBC chair is coming
to an end he's acted uh quickly in but I
suppose critics of Mr Sharp would argue
he should have acted many months ago
this report has dragged the story out
unnecessarily long and therefore he has
caused yet more damage to the
organization the corporation that he
should have been standing up for and
prioritizing in his job as chairman
Joe what really strikes me as being very
interesting in all of this uh looking
again at the statement from Richard
Sharp announcing his resignation a few
moments ago is that he stresses that
Adam heppen still found that his breach
was inadvertent and not material and
actually the BBC board appears to have
come to that conclusion so it sounds
very much so Richard Sharp retained the
backing of the BBC board
certainly allies in a business chart for
said in recent days that there are
people on the BBC board who are very
supportive of his of his contribution
on that fact of a breach of the
appointments code
it is clear and Mr Sharp recognized even
before this report was out that he had
breached uh the code
um and as you say the sort of Judgment
of Mr happenstall was was how bad was
that breach was it material breach was
it an inadvertent breach of course
um Mr Sharp argued it and has argued it
was inadvertent he clearly does have
some supporters on the BBC board and
there are certain media reports today
that that senior BBC management some
senior BBC management are publicly very
supportive of the role he has played of
course what the BBC have now with Mr
Sharp is somebody who is pretty
supportive of uh their their needing
more funding but also can communicate
with Rishi sunak well because he used to
work from a Goldman Sachs he's he is
some people within the BBC argue an
effective a communicator effective
lobbyist towards uh Mr Suna But
ultimately the bad headlines Ian he has
created in recent weeks hanging on to
his job as Miss heppenstar has been
compiling this report has been damaging
to the corporation and that I think is
ultimately why he's decided that if he
hadn't resigned now and he'd have
created even even worse headlines and
that would have been yeah damaging to
the BBC for a number of days potentially
and therefore he's therefore he's
decided to jump before he potentially
was pushed